près de nagoya à l'exposition
universelle a ouvert ses portes au
public depuis hier et jacques chirac
sera l'un de ses visiteurs attentifs à
la découverte des nombreuses innovations
technologiques présentés dans cette cité
futuriste parmi les attractions vedettes
un vrai mammouth congelé et les robots
de plusieurs générations qui font leur
show frédéric menthe et alain dumas pour
les japonais cette exposition
universelle
ils l'attendaient depuis dix ans je suis
remonté autant je suis impatient d'aller
voir l'expo est parmi les pavillons les
plus fréquentés hitachi avec son canyon
digne d'un western et toyota le numéro
deux de l'automobile mondiale exhibe ici
ces dernières aux bons musiciens des
robots prêt à se lancer dans une
carrière de rappeur aussi grande qu'un
arrondissement parisien
l'exposition universelle propose un tour
du monde 121 pays à découvrir voici
l'ukraine la russie les états unis
l'egypte ou encore l'italie très prisée
des japonais
grâce à ces carabinieri et à sa fiat 500
repeinte entièrement en chocolat
combien d'euro bonds 10000 et 12000
euros c'est pas beaucoup et c'est pas
cher la crise de foi le chocolat les
suisses auraient pu s'en servir pour
séduire les japonais mais là ils ont eu
une autre idée va faire une raclette et
vous croyez que les japonais aiment ça
ils adorent ça
aussi beau soit-il tous ces pavillons
devraient disparaître dans six mois
recyclage obligatoire hélas les japonais
ont pris de l'avancé avec leur dôme
végétal bâti en bambou